Let's go next to Ben in rural or Oregon or
rural Oregon, as some people would say.
Ben, are you there?
Ben, are you there? You've got to unmuted.
All right, no, Ben, that's too bad. Let's
go instead to Matt in rural New York. We'll
just keep it rural. What's going on, Matt?
Hey, David, big fan of the show. Thank you.
One of my favorite guests didn't get addressed
yesterday, which is fine. You know, it's hard
to keep up on all those. Yeah, they were.
They were it was explosive with Supercheap.
So one thing that I just wanted to see as
being a former election worker is one of the
questions you had, which is is there a section
for a write off in a runoff election?
And there's not an official space for that.
So it's a write in. Yeah. Yeah, right. So
let me give the back story on that. I think
it's it could spoil the ballot. Right.
So there was a question yesterday about whether
there could be candidates. Could you have
a runoff where no one gets 50 percent and
by definition in the runoff there's no write
in, there's no third party. It's the two candidates
that qualified for the runoff. It's one or
the other. And so it's mathematically impossible
to have both under 50 percent. Thanks for
clarifying that, Matt.
Correct. Yeah. So I guess my main question
was it's about the Democratic Party and its
outreach. So I know that you had those contacts
in Georgia that have been campaigning furiously
for both campaigns. Yes. You know, it's not
a secret that the Democratic Party is really
awful at outreach. And I think that was pretty
evident in the Latino vote in Florida. Yes.
So obviously, the pandemic has changed pretty
much all traditional methods of outreach.
And my question was, what do you think the
Democratic Party could do to improve outreach
not only to these minority communities in
these key battleground states, but to young
voters as well?
Well, I I think it's a good question. But
I also want to push back a little in the sense
that Joe Biden managed to win while running
a pandemic safe campaign while Trump did everything
you would do, as if there was no pandemic
going on. So as terrible as Democrats are,
they maintain control of the House. They won
the Senate and they made Trump a one term
president, all while doing it safe from the
standpoint of a pandemic. So I actually am
more encouraged by Democratic organizing in
twenty twenty because it's been so disastrous
in the past. I think they've done better with
with online. So I think obviously more can
be done. I think the Florida example is a
very good one where they were directly fighting
against these just blanket communism, socialism
fears. And I don't think that the Democratic
Party, particularly with the Latino vote,
has really figured out how to fight that yet.
So there's a huge uphill battle. You're completely
right. But I mean, I don't want the results
haven't been perfect. Democrats lost seats
in the House while maintaining control. And
there were Senate races that could have been
one which they didn't, which made it come
down to Georgia. But when you win everything,
I mean, yes, Trump is terrible and Trump damage
the Republican Party, but you can't say they're
absolutely disastrous when they won everything.
Yeah, I. I guess I meant more in a limited
context. And, you know, Georgia is very encouraging.
Yeah. And for those House elections, one of
the districts near me is the the race that's
within 12 votes and it hasn't been called
yet ripe with Claudia Tenney. That's that's
the race that trumps just going after and
saying it's corrupt. And I think he's campaigned
for her a few times here in upstate New York.
So this is really discouraging to see this.
But Georgia, you know, it's very encouraging
from the Senate standpoint. So absolutely.
Georgia, thanks, Matt. I appreciate it very,
very much.